Hello folks,
we are back live.
Few things to do today.
Few different things.
Let me pull that up and I will switch
over to the stream view.
All right.
So, uh, first and foremost here, new
article
If you're interested in uh the latest in
RL, I would suggest reading this. It's a
pretty quick read, probably like a 5 10
minute read. I wrote this this morning.
pop the chat out real quick in case uh
we'll come on to discuss it because the
bottom of it says come yell at me if you
don't like anything in here.
Okay,
so uh yeah, this is pretty much just
like a quick summary of the neural MMO
training run that we did. I did the
math. It's an absolutely ludicrous
amount of data that it turns out a 6.2 2
pedlops. It's something like comparable
to the total amount of training data
used in all language models ever. So
yeah, it's ridiculous. Hey Melor, that's
to right. Welcome, man.
We've released all sorts of stuff in the
last little bit.
So new articles here on that.
And then aside from that, we started
doing a little robotics
got back from RSS. How'd that go?
I will be at uh RLC
in a few weeks. Actually, I got to buy
my tickets.
Important thing for me to remember to
do.
Good.
Conferences can be hit or miss. So glad
that went well. Last one I went to
nearly killed me.
That's cuz we Americans aren't as tough
though.
You're dealing with like freaking
malaria and [ __ ] Like, oh no, my
pneumonia. Like,
[Music]
fix the driver problem. Need to install
nightly. Ah, I we tried to make it a
little more stable in the latest as
well. We added like some stuff,
but yeah, there's tons of cool RL around
here. And all actually works now, which
is cool.
Let me think how I want to do this. 15
over six like 4 mil.
Five mil
like
We have robotics. Uh, I added a binding
to Manny skill which is a hell of a lot
easier to use than a lot of the other
ones. Also, a stone friend of mine works
on this. I've been working on we have
some like basic task working, but we
haven't really given them the full
puffer treatment yet where we've made
them super super fast or anything.
Apparently what we're doing here.
Jeez. What did I have to do to make this
work?
I'll show what this task is in a second
here.
Oops. Come on, Chrome. Stop being weird.
Oh, saw this. It's cool.
So this is a Manny skill.
Late today I had to write this article.
Go read it.
It took me a few hours to like write
everything.
I saw this at RSS.
You probably You might have even met
Stone then. Stone's really cool in
robotic space. It was probably there.
We're starting with some of the simpler
tasks
Honestly, it's my intuition that doing
stuff like this just really really well
could be like just as useful as some of
the other stuff in robotics as a lot of
the industry bots kind of look like
this.
They follow any specific temporal logic
specifications
or non-marovian.
So one of the best things that you can
do in reinforcement learning for your
own intuition and understanding of
things is just completely ignore like
the marov property in everything. It's
not relevant.
I sent a PR on the docs. What PR did you
send on docs?
I thought I merged this.
Oh, for work in progress.
Let's see what uh
what we're getting in this train run.
Okay, so this is not solving the task
annoyingly.
Difficulty using importable APIs. How
so?
Eval's not working.
You got to give me more information than
that, right?
Welcome YouTube folks. Welcome Twitch.
Let me fix this run so I get this
working real quick and I'll pull the
article back up because I do recommend
folks read it. Um, it's kind of like a
nice showcase of some of what we can do
with RL nowadays.
I was thinking about it and I actually
think it's better than some of like the
2019 era results. Not like Dota or
anything like that, but I think this is
a better result than emergent tool use
for instance.
and we'll try to replicate it more
closely. if this works.
There are very few reinforcement
learning projects uh that have been
trained on this amount of data and all
of the other ones I'm aware of are at
large companies with lots of resources.
And the main result of this is
essentially that we actually can scale
RL not to a huge amount of hardware
necessarily, but we can train we can
scale to a massive amount of data
and we can do this in a way that you can
actually replicate on like a relatively
accessible hardware format.
Based on rental prices that I saw, I
believe that you could replicate this
experiment for less than $100 if you
were getting like good vast pricing on a
4090 spec machine.
Not bad.
Dramatically more with H00's, but it's
just like a like three days of training
uh on a single one of these tiny boxes
here.
Okay. Why are we still segting?
Oh, I'm not allowed to. Believe me, I
should have checked that.
Okay, we're just going to make sure I
didn't break the uh the baseline. We're
going to make sure that we can actually
still train this thing to like pick up
the cube or whatever. And then we're
going to try to like optimize this for
multiGPU because this is one of the rare
cases where like the training is so
obnoxiously slow and fiddly that like I
can't even really do all that much on
one GPU with this thing at the moment.
So my goal is going to be to try to
create like a multiGPU setting that's
pretty much the single GPU setting.
Exact same training run just faster.
We can go from there.
Yeah, this thing's pretty silly.
80k steps per second.
Let me look into the domain
randomization docs because I think
that's the next thing.
training speed scale linearly to number
of GPUs. uh for this it does
in terms of steps per second it does in
this with the really really fast
environments it's hard to keep them
linear but we are able to scale to like
millions of steps per second training
from stuff that's like I think neural
MMO 3 goes from 400 something thousand
to 2.2 million on six GPUs which is
pretty decent.
We haven't super optimized it either.
What needs to get done for Manny skill
exactly with Puffer? We kind of just
need to see if we can like make their
stuff run faster in Puffer or if we can
get it to train faster, right? Like
Puffer is at the moment it's pretty
highly optimized to Ms that run really
fast. So, uh the fact that these are not
super fast isn't great for us because
things we like to do like running full
hyperparameter sweeps and whatnot aren't
super easy to do. So, uh, it's a bunch
of just like fiddling with it and seeing
if we can tune knobs for puffer that
they haven't thought of before.
Like you can run it out of the box,
right? And like try to match settings,
but the thing is we don't really want to
do that because their settings are
really slow. We kind of want to like see
if we can get it into the puffer regime,
which is like the really high data fast
sim regime, and then like get the Sims
to catch up with it.
Yeah. So, I must have broken something
because we had this task succeeding
before.
Yeah. This task was like very clearly
succeeding before.
Unless it just does all of it at the
end, but I don't think that's how it
does.
Oh, control freak is way too high.
Hang on.
So, this is the original training
setting.
going to be slower.
We kind of just would like need somebody
who's done a little bit of robotics and
doesn't mind doing absolutely horrible
things to the sim in order to make it
run faster. Like from my perspective, we
kind of don't care if the sim is super
accurate. We really just want it to be
like we want it to be very fast and like
usable and then we want to randomize the
heck out of
a 46k SPS.
Why marovian property is not relevant? I
think it helps when formulating a state
for a new Enver problem.
How does it help you do that?
And basically all you're saying is like
there's some function that maps state to
next state. Um, and then you're hoping
it's not dependent on time.
Like that's all you're saying.
How does that help you?
Like a lot of the environments we train
on don't respect that property. It goes
out of the window immediately with
multi-agent for instance.
um it goes out of the window when you
have like observations for instance
don't track things that depend on time
even if the state does
like the theoretical guarantees in RL
are basically worthless
it's way more easy to think of the
agents as um learning a mapping which
can depend on time of observations to
action And that's about it.
Solves puffer eval issue. Why don't you
use any IDE?
Why would I? I've used I have used IDEs
before. They just kind of suck.
Kind of like just editing stuff in Neoim
way more.
Okay, so this works again the baseline
that we were trying to reproduce.
And now we'll see provided that this
actually trains, we will see whether we
can make this learn um 6x faster.
I think we should be able to get it to
train like 3x faster at least, not 6x,
but we'll see.
And the reason for this is because
robotic sims really really like it when
you simulate more steps uh on one GPU in
a big batch. They like to do that. So,
you can't really just like split it up
into six shards and have it be 6x
faster. It doesn't work that way. You
can actually make it six times faster by
multiplying the batch size by six, but
the thing is then the problem actually
has to be pretty hard for that to be
worth anything, which is what we'll get
to once we start domain randomizing.
Speaking of which,
they have a domain randomization thing
on here, don't they?
Yeah, domain randomization.
So camera randomization's not relevant
yet
right now. They're just randomizing the
position of the cube
pose. I don't actually know if pose is
randomized.
So this is going to be our next step, I
think, once we have it training faster
will be to do something like this.
Okay, so this works perfectly. We see
test once 12.8 million 997.
Wait for this.
Uh, do I want to go over or under? I
think I want to go over. We'll do 1024.
And then what we'll do is we'll assume
that I get
five mil.
Do like 4 mil.
Let's see if this does anything.
Domain randomization refers to physics
param randomization. contact prem
density. Uh that's another part of it
and we will do that as well. I kind of
want to like my vision for this right is
we make the problem like really fuzzy by
randomizing literally everything. Okay.
And then we scale this thing to like
20,000 robots or whatever.
And I forgot to edit the but luckily I
won't have to do this again.
have to do like this.
So, we're going to scale this thing to I
mean neural MMO it goes up to like 50k.
So, we could theoretically even go to
that and that would be faster.
It's just like we have we can't start
there because you don't actually benefit
from having more parallel agents until
the problem gets harder. And I actually
don't even know if domain randomization
is going to make training harder or
easier. It actually can go both ways.
I had control problems with not enough
to observe variables and had to think
about what to include. Yeah. So, you
don't need to think about MDP for that
though. You don't need any of the
mathematical formulism. That's literally
just from the perspective of the agent.
What information do you need to solve
the problem? That's it. There's no
mathematical formulism involved with
that. Like, there's not even any RL
involved with that. It's literally just
what information do you need to solve
the problem.
We use LSTM as a default choice. It's
not to mitigate the non-marovian prop
like the way we think about this, right?
We use LSTMs by default so that the
agents have memory. That's it.
You can attempt to interpret that
through mar like through like the thing
that you said, but it's going to be
dramatically dramatically easier and
it's going to give you the exact same
result if you just say that we add LSTM
so that the agents can have memory.
That's it.
And then there are some problems that
you don't need memory for. And there are
some problems that you do need memory
for.
And it's pretty immediately obvious for
most of them by looking at them which is
which?
You see what I mean?
We go to the mathematical formulas in
reinforcement learning when it's
actually the best way to describe what's
happening.
Okay. So something is very weird. Uh
something very weird looks like it's
going on here. Uh because
I have to reduce mini batch as well. Oh,
I probably messed that up, right?
I guess this is not really a one one.
So, we'll see whether this does the same
thing or not.
It should be pretty close though.
I'll be surprised if this doesn't at
least give us um something, you know,
like maybe it takes a little longer to
train, but it should uh in steps, but it
should actually give us something that's
at least faster than uh wall clock. But
hopefully
it's like it's not that I hate math,
Right. It's that I hate when we use math
to like when we use very heavy math to
describe very simple things where the
math adds exactly zero additional
precision and clarity. And I see it all
the time in RL.
Okay. I mean, this is like slightly
better of a result.
This should maybe learn something. We'll
see.
problem is linear and interpretable.
Yeah, but the thing is if the problem is
linear and interpretable like all this
stuff is useless. Like why are you
wasting your time studying linear
problems?
So this is like one of my pet peeves,
right, with how a lot of these things
are taught. They'll like spend time
making you do like proofs or making you
like solve equations on like problems
that just don't matter
like nobody is working on how do we
design better RL for linear problems.
yeah, we are solving.
Cool. So, and it is a little faster in
wall clock even though we have not
reuned parameters or anything. Okay. So,
this is like acceptable sub three
minutes per experiment.
We can at least like make progress with
things at this rate.
When things get to like five plus minute
experiments, I get annoyed because it's
like
what am I going to do? I just guess I
hang out and I yap for five minutes
between runs.
and
I think I ran at 30 mil.
Current reward function justified in
Manny skill.
Uh, their rewards were not. I changed
them and now they are.
Sometimes they take 15 minutes. You need
to get real hardware, my friend. CPUs
are not real hardware for RL.
And this robotic stuff is super slow. So
like I have a server for it, but like
all the other stuff in Puffer, you can
just run it on a desktop. We have people
running with like basically whatever
GPU. It's can't you can't be doing stuff
on CPU. It'll be like 20 times faster
than if you do it on CPU and another RL
library. But we can only work so much
magic.
Only do so much.
Here's our multiGPU baseline.
If I do real time,
if I do relative time, you can see it is
better in relative time than our uh
previous experiment. So good. A. Okay.
Okay. So, we'll have to figure out how
we do this.
Think we can do RL on cyersc. I've
talked to a few people about that
probably.
You can always toggle with how position
rewardsation
combined. Uh there was a much more
fundamental problem, Sean, that I had to
fix.
uh they were doing rewards in a way that
just do not make sense for standard RL
outside of robotics. And like basically
they had two errors that canceled each
other out. And like all of robotics
people do this apparently, but I just
like I did it the same way where you
don't need to go make two errors to
cancel each other out. And it's just
correct.
Sometimes they provide intuition to a
bigger empirical problem
as far as I can.
I hear what you're saying, Kovac, but
I've seen the way the RL is taught and
it's a mess.
Like, if you just look at like our quick
start guide and like the resources I
link in the quick start guide and how
much faster you will actually be able to
solve stuff and understand things that
matter, it's a world of difference. It
advance. So, basically, and this is this
is no shame to the manny skill guys,
okay? Because everybody in robotics does
this stuff and they all do it wrong.
What they do is they do these
state-based rewards where they say like,
okay, your reward goes up as you get
closer to the target. All right?
And the reason that this is wrong is
because when you're right next to the
target, you have maximal reward.
So, you're incentivized to just sit
there forever and do nothing because you
farm more reward. That is what is wrong
with the way that roboticists specify
their rewards.
To get around this, they do this
infinite horizon bootstrap thing, which
basically says that you pretend that
you're going to keep going forever and
that's the reward that you'll actually
get. And they change the way advantage
estimation works in order to do that.
But that's going to break learning for a
ton of other environments because it
basically says you get reward beyond the
current episode. Um, you don't get like
a penalty for terminating.
So, it's a much more specialized
implementation. And the thing is, you
don't need to do any of this. Literally,
all they had to do is just take their
current reward, right? And take the
delta from the current reward to the
reward at the previous time step. That's
your new reward function. And now all
those problems go away. It was like
three lines of code.
Why is command line interface slow
compared to importable?
What do you mean why is it slow?
you get faster training speed or is it
like is it just that it takes a second
to show up? Because if it's that it
takes a second to show up, that's
because Torch like PyTorch takes like a
second to import.
It's very silly that we have packages in
Python that take like a second or two to
import, but that is the state of
software.
How do I do this? Me get rid of that
bot.
I import it's closer to 600K. Then
something's got to be different, right?
like settings or something got to be
different.
The command line is literally just a
wrapper around that.
Could be default args. I don't know. It
depends how you're loading configs.
Is our RL stars fair? Yeah.
I mean, you see the thing, the way that
we build stuff around here, it's like
a lot of stuff in RL is just it's
mindboggling how badly done a lot of the
things are, right? Like look, I
shouldn't be able to make RL a thousand
times faster. Okay? When a field is done
competently, it's like a big deal if you
make something two times faster or two
times better, right? That's like a huge
deal, right? When stuff is like I make
it a thousand times faster, that just
means the original was just a total
mess, right?
Let's see if we can figure out this pose
logic stuff. And since we do have a fair
few folks on YouTube, a few quick
things. One is there's a a new article
today. It's on X. You can get it right
here, Jars 531. I post all the stuff
here. So, if you want to see how you can
do reinforcement learning on a pabyte of
data with a relatively uh mediocre
hardware setup, not a $300,000 server
right here. And then generally, I stream
all this stuff live. It's all open
source at puffer.ai.
The GitHub to help us out. And you can
get involved with the development on the
Discord right here. Well, back to Dev.
There's not really a way around this,
but they they kind of want you to
subclass their stuff.
How do we do this for um
for the panda robot
Little tricky to figure out how we're
supposed to do this.
Let me just message Stone to see if he's
on.
Maybe he can help us get us started on
this quicker. If not, I'll just figure
it out.
a custom environment. When you load the
scene,
we definitely need to just get a base
scene loaded. Let's do that first.
What is epoch? epoch is the number of uh
training steps that have run like
collect a bunch of data, you train on
the data, that's one epoch.
We're going to just temporarily force
this to be
upper
buffer pick
cube.
And I guess we can pass all this stuff
directly maybe.
Hopefully we can get a good domain
randomized config quite quickly here.
We'll see.
I think I know how we should go about
it. If we just open up the uh the
source,
I believe they randomized the uh the
goal position.
Oh, maybe they don't randomize the goal
position at all.
this is 000.
Kind of confusing honestly. I don't know
where they're setting positions and
things in here.
Okay, so this works apparently, but um
I'm not seeing any logs. So something is
screwy.
Episode and epochs are the same. Um, no.
So, an episode Well, where do you see
episodes? I don't think we record that
as a stat. You see episode return and
episode length that is for like one
agent's interactions with one
environment. How long is that? So how
many steps and then what is the summed
summed reward?
The epochs is like a bunch of episodes.
A whole bunch of uh episodes are in each
epoch.
Does anybody understand how they have
this set up?
Cube spawn center
register M does not define. Okay.
Go XYZ.
Okay. Uh pose.create from PQ
positioning quaternian. Okay.
So this is randomizing I believe just
the initial cube site
and not the is it the goal?
Oh no it is randomizing the
some aspect of it.
Okay. So this runs now. We'll make sure
that this frames.
We actually do have our ability though
to to mess with it now.
Oh, I understand. So, this is just
loading all the stuff and then on
initialize episode
they uh they move the thing. So, really
all we need to do
change the initialize episode
potentially,
And we should also probably get this on
our local
Yeah, so this is the default setup.
It does randomize the cubes
position
It does drop it occasionally as well,
which is interesting.
as this works. We didn't break the
environment.
Now we can attempt to break the
This
you need this
uh do we let me See, does this always
start the robot at the same spot?
Looks like the robot's pretty much
always in the same spot, right?
table scene
robot.
tell you how to move the uh the robot
agent robot and controller
randomizations.
Yeah, this can be done during
initialized episodes.
Environment episode current is the
parameter that tells us the agent is
learn. It depends on the environment,
but yes,
some environments have a score. Most of
them should have a score in puffer lib.
That's the actual like metric you care
about. Episode return is the summed
reward, the metric the agencies that
it's optimizing.
slightly different, but they'll both
tell you things.
When it's flat, it means the agent's not
learning anything. If the score is flat
as well, then yes.
How do I make the robot start at a
different spot?
like
Uh it depends which num ms param you
mean.
If you set like a lot of the ends uh
like vec num ms param to zero like to
one it's not going to learn if you set
num ms to one it's not going to learn
anything.
If you set those to 20 then you have
you're going to have a ludicrous number
of agents.
Like if you change it if you change the
default to 20 you're going to have like
20,000 agents in parallel. You don't
have hardware for that and then only
some of the environments will benefit
from that.
Helicopter just went over flying super
low.
The settings that I have as defaults are
probably going to still be roughly ideal
because like
you'd have to rerun a whole sweep just
for CPU if you want to see what the
fastest solve time is. At least the
settings that I provided I know work,
right?
Robot init pause noise.
The robot init pause noise. Can I crank
this up?
So, this should make uh the robot start
at all sorts of different spots.
We can change the
change the robot like joint stuff.
That's probably important.
I wanted to change like size of cube and
stuff.
Ah,
but here
Starting to learn
if we just can run it for longer.
A lot of things you can change in theory
soon.
For everything must be rough. No, I Why
would I do it this way if it were
difficult? I do it this way because it's
easy.
The one annoying thing is I don't have
my Neovim on the tiny box. So like my
autocomplete and stuff isn't working
nicely.
I've used IDs before. They're just slow
and shitty.
Okay,
this is doing something now.
So, let's see. There's collision meshes
visual messages
point PD
mass inertia
initial mean joint position
roller choice.
We have to be a little careful not to do
stuff that just makes the task
impossible.
I don't think that's what's happening
here, though.
This seems like unstable learning or
something.
Set it to 0.1 for now and see what
happens.
I don't want it to like spawn through
the table or something, right?
Mass inertia
point PD
How do you fund this project? Do you
work somewhere else? Puffer is a
company. So, we have a couple companies
that we work with. Generally, you can
hire Puffer to help with your
reinforcement learning efforts. We have
all sorts of tools. Uh, reinforcement
learning is hard. We make it easier.
Generally, a lot of our stuff just
solves a lot of problems out of the box.
Um, the ones that it doesn't we help
with.
Okay. Okay, so this initial pose at
least gives us some reasonable success
right here.
I don't know if this is going to be
stable.
This seems like it's unstable a little
bit.
at
still don't even know what the
observations are, right?
What are the observations?
Okay. So they have added the
obvious
grasp.
Full pause.
pose raw pose.
I need to understand what this data is
next.
PCP pose
need to understand whether this is
reasonable. Next.
just stick some break points in here and
start looking at data.
Uh, okay. This is interesting.
The cube also has a 7D pose.
Position and orientation of the robot.
Uh, what is environment?
This is Manny skill. This is a robot
picking up a cube and moving it to a
goal.
So, is this position XYZ and then like a
quitterian?
P
and Q.
Yeah. Environment slashn on your ocean
n. Oh, n is the number of data points
that were collected in displaying that
summary.
Last four straight up like quturnians.
Yeah.
So that's weird though.
A robot is described by a root pose and
point angles.
hit cube only. It doesn't have anything
to do with the cube though. It has to do
with the robot, right? The robot is a
like six degree of freedom or whatever
arm
You always provide Q pause and velocity
extra obs specific data.
Okay, I see.
Yeah. Okay. So, apparently there's a
base there's a base observation for all
the robots.
Get OBS agent. Get OBS extra.
Get proprioception.
Looks like a pain. Yeah, it is a pain in
the ass, but it's dramatically less of a
pain in the ass than the other robotics
libraries.
This is like less, believe it or not,
this is like less overly abstracted and
ridiculous by a mile compared to like
Isaac
in base agent.
And then this calls get state
and get get pause get velocity.
So they actually are including then the
information that seems
mostly reasonable.
I think that this is mostly done
correctly.
I guess it's difficult to know because
of the coordinates schemes, right?
Okay, this is one that actually has like
a pretty simple reward. That's probably
correct.
Then what makes this like remotely
difficult or interesting, I guess, is my
question,
right?
What makes this remotely difficult?
probably just comes down to
randomization. Now,
I do it here.
Builds all objects and all parallel M
and share same physical properties.
Boards are dense. So it has to work
unless problem works. But I'm trying to
figure out what makes the problem like
remotely difficult to learn.
I mean to be fair it does learn in like
a ridiculously short number of time
steps uh by like our standards of our
other environments just the end is so
unbelievably Hello.
That's the main limitation more than
anything is just it's order of magnitude
minimum too slow.
Like minimum
full
pull center point.
Okay, so this is competently done.
Okay.
On
Here's
I could I think I think I see now with
like robotics how you could do this from
just a couple demos.
I don't think what we have to do that
they're just loading some states.
being the issue, right? is that it
doesn't
doesn't learn anywhere near as Well,
Getting started with RL. Welcome.
This is the place for it.
I think we're just going to have to run
a bunch of random experiments with how
slow this thing is is and hope we find
something start with.
Like it's not like it doesn't work, it's
just not optimal.
this
first thing to try. That's kind of
obvious.
It's already a massive learning rate,
but no, screw it. Why not?
It's just like it's annoying that this
is basically they've kind of like
managed to bring RL back to the dark
ages with the the slow sims here.
Realistically,
I'd have to add
I'd have to add multiGPU
sweeps, I think.
Why is it not learning
with
you're using 32,000 environments? That's
why you have a huge number of
environments for a relatively simple
problem. It's not going to benefit from
that amount of parallelism.
U because the config for that end
probably doesn't have end numm set to
eight. Got this from your example. Which
example has that?
portable. Oh yeah, that's just that's
just showing you like a random that's
not like meant to be a good config for
whatever env, right? They're showing you
the API
visual will be barely paralyzed at 1024
m
per GPU.
Okay, this does something, but I don't
think it learns like fast, right?
So, this it learns, but it takes forever
here.
That doesn't do it.
go mess with the panda.
Where?
Okay. So that's
make the robot faster. There.
Are you running multi-en
You're running multi-en 4096? How come
it's slow? This thing here, uh, this is
slow because this is a robotic sim,
which is just slow. It's not a puffer
end. Our puffer ms are fast.
Okay. So, this learns like
maybe a little bit faster.
Okay. So, increasing the actions kind of
did something.
I'm going to go like just 5x the force
limits and stuff as well.
You say it slows comparing apples and
bananas. Whole engines do tons of
calculations.
[Music]
Honestly, it's like six degrees of
freedom in one cube. I think it's kind
of just slow.
Like particularly when I look at the
code and how the code is written, it's
like
I bet it's just slow.
If I want to write an NVC, what do I
have to do? We have a tutorial for that
on the docs page.
I'm thinking about it and it's like
there's no way you wouldn't be able to
run a fixed degree of freedom arm at
like millions. Totally should be able
to. Really not doing anything that
crazy.
Now, you find sweet spot for training
config. Not the way I'm doing it here.
Automated uh automatic sweeps.
Don't do what I'm doing here.
Crazy. Contact sim with what? There's
nothing for it to contact.
uh puffer sweep. It should also be in
the docs. We have a sweep. We have like
a really nice hyper pram sweep algo
built in.
Let's just I'm just kind of yoloing a
few things here because like
the way that it's set up just can't be.
It like just can't be the best way of
doing it.
It's just no way you need to have it be
so high fidelity that it's low.
All right. We'll see if this does
anything.
This should allow it to just like flail
about very very quickly if it wants to.
realistic collision checks for complex
meshes even though they are
rectangularistically
doing a lot of realism. Well, then they
shouldn't be doing that, right?
The idea of like I want to train a good
robot, therefore I will simulate this
thing as realistically as I possibly
can, train it on that and then deploy
it. That's just wrong. That's not how it
works
because if you just have no data, right?
If you have basically no data and it's
very high fidelity, doesn't matter.
I'd rather be able to train something at
relatively lower fidelity with a ton of
randomization such that I get a really
really robust policy out of it.
It doesn't matter if I can simulate
physics if I have something that can
like work correctly on basically any
sort of janky physics setup that you
give it. Right?
That's the idea.
how you deploy it because if it works on
any randomized set of physics,
collisions, etc. If it works on like all
randomized versions, then the real
version is in there somewhere, right?
So, think about it, right? one option
one you make it as realistic as
possible. Okay. And then you deploy you
train it on that it's really really slow
and you deploy it and then your SIM is
not exactly like the real world. So
there's still a big annoying gap, right?
Option two is that you randomize the
heck out of everything such that you're
not remotely training on something that
looks like the real world, but the real
world is in there somewhere in all the
configs that you have.
is determined by the sim to real gap
too.
Um kind of but it's easier because like
domain randomization gives you a big
wide distribution over the real like
over
it gives you a big wide distribution
that hopefully the real one's in there
somewhere.
Okay. Yeah. So, this is taking longer to
learn with random action. So my guess is
that it's just like
I mean, something's got to give because
the Sims are just abysmally horribly
slow.
Like, you're literally in the dark ages
where like nothing works because you
have no data.
This right here is running at less than
5% of the speed of um you know my more
complex M training runs
and like a hundth of the speed of the
faster ones
for like a really easy task. like a task
that when you look at the task and you
assess the difficulty of the task like
it's trivial.
You have this being this slow for a
problem that is trivial.
And this is the thing that we found with
reinforcement learning as well. Stuff
feels really difficult because it's
slow. That's it.
It's like this is why you had like
generations of RL students like working
on Pong and stuff, right? Like, well,
was ponging hard? No, it was just slow.
You can't optimize like all the all the
experiment settings, all the
hyperparameters suck, okay? All the
environment settings suck, okay? Like
literally nothing is optimized correctly
at all because you can't run enough
experiments because it's slow.
Exact same thing happened in the rest of
RL.
How to best understand config from
command. Yeah. So, Neptune will give you
logs and you can see which experiments
are the best and then you can kind of
just pick one and grab the config
parameters from there.
It's like I can't even really like the
thing is I can't even really get into
this type of stuff I'd want to do with
the way this is set up. It's like not
intended for the type of stuff I want to
do.
We have any war sims? Uh yeah, the one I
was working on the other Okay.
didn't sacrifice the realism.
Let me see how I can convince you with
this
quite
like literally this is all I'm asking
for. Okay, take literally every single
physics parameter in here, right?
like every single like you know force
parameter, gravity, inertia like just
take all the parameters
okay
and then define some like percentage
based interval over them.
We should be able to tune the magnitude
of that interval.
And then all the other parameters that's
like solver fidelity and updates and all
that stuff should also go into the tuner
and then we should figure it out
automatically and algorithmically.
Roboticists are not doing that at the
moment.
They're kind of just assuming that they
just make the thing as slow as human
like un like as slow as they can
possibly bear
and then they just run their really slow
experiments and hope it works.
Is that a hardware thing though? Like
can't you get around that with other
types of grippers?
the dynamics are straight. I don't see
any fluid dynamics or cloth draping
though is the thing. Like look, I don't
see fluid dynamics. I don't see cloth.
I see ultra basic rigid body physics,
right? With like a literally trivial
task.
Hang on, let me show you the one that
I'm looking at.
It's like pig cube.
Okay, if you want to think about like in
terms of how complex like to learn this
behavior from first principles
in my head, this is like pong.
We kind of just get sensor data.
Okay. Okay. Easier than pong. I mean,
like
What is the decision making involved
with picking up a thing?
It's like a few joint angles.
Can't you spawn more than 4K? Yes, you
can. But here's the problem. The thing
is really simple problems don't lend
themselves to actually learning faster
with more environments. Serial
as the environment gets harder, you can
benefit from more parallel Ms. The thing
is this is just a very bad combination.
It's a simple problem that's really
slow.
Simple and very slow.
Do you know how many Do you know how
long it takes us to learn pong in Puffer
Lib?
3 seconds. It takes us three seconds to
learn a uh like a 20 score pong policy.
It has to learn pretty fast. Yeah. The
thing is it just doesn't learn fast.
This number is 20 times too slow.
Actually, more than 20 times too slow.
Pong trains 20 times faster than this on
a sixth of the hardware. So, it's over
100x too slow. And I see the rewards
again. The rewards are very sly defined.
I will show you.
So, this is how they compute a dense
reward.
Okay,
they have a reward for reaching the goal
and then they have a is a grasping term.
You only get a reward for placing the
object if you're actually grasping it.
And then I have the static reward. These
are state based rewards. So completely
wrong. Uh but what we do is we take the
delta between this at this step and at
the previous step. So delta of reward at
previous uh this step to previous step
tells you progress towards goal and
that's what we use as reward.
I don't know if we're getting hit by a
hurricane or what, but everything is
rattling and shaking.
Those
Hopefully this doesn't take out the
stream. We'll see.
Why do you do that? And what's wrong
with this reward?
The state based rewards
when you get close to the goal, you'll
just hover around it forever and you'll
not actually solve the task.
This is a wrong way to define rewards.
And then what the roboticists do is they
modify generalized advantage estimation
to bootstrap on terminals.
We do instead is we just don't do that
and we use delta rewards and it's the
same thing actually better because you
actually get more fidelity out of your
reward signal.
It seems pretty easy. Well, we do solve
it. It's just like it's proven annoying
to get it to solve faster.
I can kind of try to just guess a couple
things.
Yeah, that's basically
the problem. The thing is it's not that
my general like it's not that my
advantage estimate is wrong, right? My
advantage estimate is right. In general,
the robotics version of it is wrong.
At the very least, they have a
specialized J that doesn't work with
other types of tasks. Mine will work
with both provided you don't define the
reward the rewards insanely like Yes.
very weird to me how
volatile the rewards are, you know.
Makes sense.
I see.
What if you continuously increase the
reward?
So because you normally you clip it off
at the last state, it's going to rather
it would rather stay right next to the
goal, right? Then get reset to the start
where it's going to get very low go like
a very low reward.
Yeah. So, what's it's going to do is
it's going to like go right next to the
goal and then just sit there. And then
if it's a smart, eventually it'll figure
out to touch the goal at the very end.
But probably not.
Add an action to the termination. The
way easier solution, right, is to just
not define your rewards like this
is not this is not a good way to define
rewards at all anyways because like you
compress the entire signal as well.
The delta between one state and another
state might be very small in terms of
difference in reward.
a ridiculous gamma though. I guess it's
because it's a dense reward.
Never trust no RL algorithm to work on a
new endeavor.
The thing is ours actually does like we
got it working on this pretty quickly.
As soon as we fix the rewards, we have
it working on this new end in a new
domain that we don't do like out of the
box.
Uh it's just that the env is very slow
and we would like it to be faster. So
I'm looking for settings where it's
faster and we can still learn.
But yeah, actually try try the Puffer 3
trainer. actually works out of the box
on most stuff. It's kind of crazy.
I wonder if I ought to just like sync
this up to the environment resets, you
know?
Okay. So, it suddenly is at least like
somewhat better.
Yeah. But it looks like the hyper prams
we swept from before are like overall
reasonable.
not terminating the end in case at all.
Then you'll stop learning because all
the agents will get to the goal position
and you just don't reset. You're getting
worthless data.
Okay, let's hope my roof is really good.
cuz uh this is a gale outside. My gosh.
Holy.
My microphone should mostly be filtering
it, but it's uh rain on a metal roof.
So,
very loud. Ah, look at this.
Okay.
Now my question is with these more
general hyperparams
where we haven't like maxed the learning
rate
can we go up to
4096NS
and 32
32 384
And to be safe, I'm getting a very high
quality conversation on RL, which I
can't get at all in the day.
Yeah, I mean, this is the place. Look, I
don't even really do robotics. We're
kind of just doing this as like, yeah,
robotics is another RLN. And it's not
like we're failing, right? Like the
stuff works. It's just that I would like
I'd like to find some settings to
massively improve the speed here. But
the thing is like my intuition here is
just that like this thing has been I've
seen this all the time in the rest of
RL, right? You have like an environment
that's been very heavily tuned to work
in like the defaults. It doesn't mean
that there aren't other ways to set it
up. It's just very annoying and like a
lot of work. My guess is that like if
you actually have a very heavily
randomized setting with way way lower
fidelity uh solver params,
my estimate here is that it actually
will do just as well, if not better.
So that's what I'd like to do, but it's
kind of becoming clear that it's pretty
tough to set that type of stuff up.
I at least want to see if we can like
get something that's meaningful though,
like some sort of meaningful improvement
to this thing.
This is like the reward is just not
quite doing it for us.
I could keep the mini batch small,
right?
How would you define the reward for this
problem? Can you elaborate on this?
Because I'm bumping this into a spot.
Well, I I actually have it. So, the
reward I showed you is not what I'm
training on. That's their original.
Okay. The reward that I have is
literally just that reward that I showed
you computed at the current time step
minus that reward at the previous time
step.
So, that tells you progress towards
goal. It's unfarmmable. Because if you
stay at a point, you get zero. Can't go
back and forth because that just
averages out to be zero. You get a
positive when you go towards the the
goal. This will work for like any of the
dense reward signals that the
roboticists have set up. So like
literally they were a threeline change
away from having it here.
Hypothesize a little bit.
Start with
is the original reward good at all?
Uh, it's it contains good information,
but it's not presented correctly. Let's
put it that way. So, literally, if you
just take their reward signal and make
it delta instead of absolute, it works.
You don't need to do IRL like inverse
RL.
The thing I've given works, right? This
this does work.
We take some more steps than they do to
solve it, but like we're literally
training one update epoch as well. I
haven't messed with that a whole bunch
yet.
you have a totally new end. How would
you design one?
Uh, I can't really comment on robotics
because I don't do like a ton of
robotics. their rewards are like they're
very manual and kind of a pain, but like
I see why they do the things. They're
just posed wrong. So when I look when I
design new environments and I have
rewards, I usually do the simplest thing
possible, right? Like I start with just
success and then if it's like obvious
that that's way way way too hard to run
into, which is like basically if you
take random actions and you're never
going to get the success condition, you
can't just train on that. So then I try
to do like the most lighthanded
intermediate reward I possibly can,
usually some sparse thing, right? And
then if I end up with more complex that
have like three or four different reward
coefficients, uh then I just like I
think okay, here are three or four
important things in the environment. I
don't know what their relative waiting
is and I put them into a hyperparameter
sweep.
Welcome.
Thank you. Yeah, I actually was just
going through all the YouTube comments
uh this morning. I was like, "Hey,
actually, surprisingly, YouTube is way,
way, way happier about all this stuff
than X's." X, they're always mad about
everything. People here are pretty
chill.
Okay. Yay. This actually kind of works.
Is it better?
Oh, actually this is quite good, isn't
it? Because if I do this,
look at that.
And that's our fastest solve yet. Two
minutes.
Let me think if I can make sense of what
I even just did. I kind of just guessed.
So I reduce the total batch size by a
factor of four.
I can try eight.
This is where things start to get
sketchy.
I can try eight. If this works better,
it just means the problem's trivial, by
the way,
which is kind of expected. Like they use
four in uh the original. Like this
parameter they use like four steps
which is crazy like absolutely crazy
why don't you use different algorithm
what do you mean
we have um
at least as far as online learning goes
like we kind of have the best thing
already in puffer
we don't like hop between a bunch of
different algor algorithms. We just have
the best algorithm.
this uh re this is also not exactly PO
like the changes that we have in our
implementation are substantial enough to
consider it a new algorithm and like in
performance it's a generational
advancement over PO and I mean that for
real this time not like all the papers
that claim to be better and like
actually aren't this one's like for real
for real better.
Sounds like a paper material.
I'm so sick of papers.
We have some blogs on it on X if you
want all the details. It's all open
source.
The idea that every time you come up
with something useful, you have it has
to be exactly eight dense pages of
really boring content is like it takes a
year to review is like kind of
ludicrous.
Get to a place to make a pitch. Yeah, I
do that. I mean, like with I have like a
good chunk of the RL audience on X as
like already. If you look at like the
biggest pure RL accounts and then you
look at the size of mine, it's they're
pretty close to comparable.
Particularly because I really don't have
followers from like other stuff, right?
They're like professors and things that
have like they post politics and other
stuff and they have larger accounts, but
like as for people that are just there
because they post pure RL, it's pretty
good.
You think that those people on X are
real?
I mean, yeah. I get messages from
researchers all the time.
Okay, so I was kind of expecting this to
work. The fact that it doesn't is
actually kind of a good thing.
What's What license does Puffer use? MIT
free.
The only thing that we sell is we sell
uh we sell our services, right? You can
use all our stuff for free, but if you
you have an RL problem and you're having
a hard time with it in industry, you can
hire us to help. That includes like
support and features around Puffer Lib
that includes direct work on your
problem, custom simulation work, all
that type of stuff.
sement filtering
topics off.
Okay, so we're at 16. Horizon was the
good one.
I guess we just see if we can mess with
fidelity now, right?
Does this still learn?
We should in theory be a little bit more
robust to fidelity now because we have
massive batches.
We have a a good number of folks on
YouTube today. Hello, welcome.
If you're new around here, this is just
all sorts of reinforcement learning
research done live. It's all open
source. If you want to see a bunch of
demos that are not me just staring at uh
training graphs because we're doing
fiddly robotics today. We have all sorts
of stuff at puffer.ai,
click ocean. You can see all these
different demo ming
demo to games
like this this type of a thing. And the
agents all run in your browser. And many
of these were contributed by uh brand
new people with like zero RL experience
coming in.
So, if you're interested in getting
involved in building crazy stuff Oh,
yeah. I like this one. I built this one.
Each puffer is a different agent.
If you want to get involved with this,
you can join the Discord, which is just
discord.gg/puffer.
You can also help us out for free by
starring the GitHub. Also, follow me on
X for more.
If I have stalled long enough, maybe the
policy will have trained.
kind of
is this stable is my question.
does take longer
steps.
Where's RL used in industry side aside
from releasing things R1 or is it just
catching on? It's a lot of random
problems.
Like RL is basically any anytime you
have a sim and like a fiddly unintuitive
optimization problem.
We've done all sorts of like weird
random things. The thing is like RL has
just kind of been cast to the wayside
because nobody could get it to work. But
like nobody could get it to work because
everybody did all the engineering wrong.
So just in the last year we've made so
many things a thousand times faster.
We've been able to like make some
fundamental algorithm breakthroughs. Uh
we've been able to like really really
hone in and optimize a bunch of things.
And now it it feels like a different
field at the very least. If nothing
else, it feels like a totally different
field from
Okay, this is actually pretty solid.
We're at like two minute solve. Super
low fidelity.
Can we crank up control?
Demos on the website are fun to play
with. Thank you.
We had to do quite a bit of stuff to get
those to work.
So those all of those agents those are
running like pure C versions of the
neural nets that we trained in PyTorch.
So we take the PyTorch weights, we load
them into like this single file C
library that we made and then compile
all that to web assembly including the
environments.
What do you think about VALA's?
LA
VMs or VAS.
What's a VA?
Very large action models. I don't know.
action models. Eh,
if you get enough data for a specific
enough problem, sure. I kind of really
don't care what's happening in the world
of like let's train massive like
ridiculously sized models that are super
slow
because like
it's kind of funny that we are we're
able to like solve like individual
problems in seconds with these like
absolutely tiny models that you can just
deploy anywhere.
And like obviously this is a lot newer
in the sense that it hasn't had billions
of dollars of investment poured into it,
but like you can kind of see just from
the progress we've made in the last year
where some of this is going.
So this isn't a thing that they thought
I would be able to get to work already.
That's exciting.
Can I do
let me think about this a little bit
carefully
BLM with imitation.
Any wisdom on metalarning
hyperparameters?
I've been going off the heristic that if
puffer doesn't do it then it can't be
great. Yes, except there's one small
caveat. Finn, there was one quirk with
our hyperparam sweep algorithm that I
could not fix uh in time for release. If
you see that your problem is forcing all
the runs to be the minimum number of
time steps
that you specify in the sweep, you might
want to try uh with one of like the down
sample equals zero configs.
And what that does is that basically it
tells the hyperparam sweep algorithm to
not try to learn using the entire
training curve to just use the end
point. And that's kind of needed for
some of the environments.
Let me think about this a little bit
more principled if I can. Um,
Let's actually see what this does. I'm
curious.
I think this just gives you like fake
additional fake frames.
like approaching a respectable training
speed
I will say this, the defaults that we
have in Puffer Lib work on like almost
all the environments.
Like they work out of the box on a huge
number of problems, but we're getting
closer to that.
I think we could get to a point where
like we have defaults that work pretty
darn well out of the box on almost
everything. The main thing, the main
thing that is not solved yet is gamma.
So generalized advantage estimation
imposes a horizon on your tasks and it's
really screwy. So we would have to like
we'd basically have to come up with a
replacement for generalized advantage
estimation.
That was through a search. Yeah. But the
thing is we did the search once. All
right. We did the search on like
breakout and those same parameters work
on like at least six or eight of the
environments. It just works.
I think more like 12 of them actually.
Really the only ones it doesn't work
like the bigger models need different
learning rates and you can show that you
need to decrease the learning rate and
then there's some environments that need
different gamas.
model based dynamics based agent can
solve the hyper prim. No, they can't.
How do you figure?
What part about having a model solves
hyperparameter tuning?
If you quote the dreamer paper, I'm
going to submit a different academic
paper back at you. Fair warning.
Mr. Q. I've been meaning to look at
that. It's like big paper. Been meaning
to look at that
model. Well,
there's something to modelbased RL, I
think. But the thing is like
it's like the rest of RL where all the
science is done absolutely horribly. So,
it's kind of hard to tell.
So, this thing just doesn't do very
well. Um,
You go find the thing that he told me to
adjust.
arm
point delta pause.
Okay, so this is what he told me
and this is what he told me to mess
with. So let me see if this does
anything.
I actually think some of them use zero
line of work makes more sense.
Like that makes more sense to me. Some
of it does.
I think a lot of the a lot of the
algorithm work I want to do will look at
off uh off policy as well as model based
but like we kind of have to just throw
puffer liib on a bunch of different
applications first, right?
Gain some more industry traction.
So, if this doesn't work, then there's
something that's not behaving as is uh
as anticipated
because technically
if we double the SIMs, like if we double
the control frequency and we double the
actions, it should work just the same.
I'm going to run this first to make sure
it doesn't actually work.
Yeah. So this is very similar to the
ABS.
How can you run multiple sweeps in
parallel
like for different environments
and just launch different processes on
different GPUs?
Uh we don't have the ability to use
multiple GPUs in the same sweep yet.
That is something that we should add. We
do have the ability to do multiGPU
training.
Uh, we don't have the ability to do use
like multiple GPUs where each GPU
contributes to the same sweep.
That's one of the things I've been
meaning to add.
different process.
New man
out of here. See you. Thank you.
I do this pretty much every day.
See, this is obnoxious because if we
could get this to work
like this is the theoretical max SPS
that I've obtained with this, right?
YouTube comments pretty slow.
Yeah, the latency is a little better on
Twitch. Not much I can really do about
YouTube being YouTube.
Let me just try one like one weird thing
just in case.
like just in case
which is that technically you have to
increase gamma
the way it's defined here
because you create a longer horizon
problem.
Go back to the original 20.
I do like this.
You managed to train 2048 and put it on
the website. I have not done that yet.
Yanick,
I need to do that though because that is
a cool environment. I've been
sidetracked by robotics and other
things.
do have a cool new article up though
if you want to figure out uh if you want
to hear how we did RL on a pabyte of
data one server
here's a nice write up here on X
I did
if this is stable.
You have fully integrated multiGPU. Yes,
we do.
you ve the no that's not how you do it
and that's not how you'd want to do it.
If you did it that way then you would
like you'd multiply the overhead of any
CPU operation by the number of GPUs. So
we use torch run which launches
independent processes per trainer and
then DDP just averages the gradients.
Does it scale two GPUs double as fast?
Depends on your environment speed.
If you from the article, right, 2.2
million training steps per second for a
neural MMO 3 compared to like 400
between 400 and 500k on one GPU.
To be fair, that's not even completely
fair because uh there's like some CPU
conflicts as well doing neural MMO like
that
overhead there as well.
Depends on your environment can be
linear.
Amusingly, we've managed to take more
steps to solve in about the same amount
of time.
But the uh the hope here is that this
will now allow us to
do better.
We wanted to preserve the number of
gradient updates,
make learning more stable.
What happens if I do like this?
Let's do 16384
update
2.
That should be the same number of
updates to the policy
Welcome to all the uh stream's been
doing well the last couple of days.
We'll of course have to actually look at
the policy. I don't want to run too many
more of these because I got to run for
dinner uh a little bit before 6.
Like to be able to look at it.
I'd like some of these articles on X to
do better. I mean, they they take quite
a bit of time to write.
Amusingly, like the literally like AI
clipped shorts out of the stream have
done like surprisingly well on YouTube.
They get like over a thousand views. I
think one of them got like 2,000
something. The other got a thousand. are
just like literally clips from this
random stuff I do. I don't know what's
up with the shorts algorithm, but I
don't know if I if I do anything like
interesting like an explanation of
something or other, I might just start
adding those.
We're comparing this one
to this one.
We have something.
We have this metric.
Huh.
Yeah. See, this is one of those weird
things I can't even explain.
This should pretty much always be
strictly better.
Oh, no. It does track. Hang on. It's
actually starting to track this.
Okay, so it's pretty close to
comparable.
Uh, which means that we're not really
benefiting from larger mini batches.
Played with a couple config brims. Got a
good run in 15 minutes training
multiGPU.
Solid.
Yeah, we really need to do multiGPU
sweeps. I think Spencer, I just haven't
had the chance to add it. It kind of
takes a little bit of work.
Do this instead. So, this is doubling
the number of updates. It's a very
different thing. This will be the last
run we'll do. After this, we'll like
well the last new run we'll do. After
this, we'll train our baseline. Uh we'll
grab the policy. We'll like output some
rendering and we'll call it
Alternative title for stream will be
watch as I horribly break break all of
your Sims roboticists
in order to make them actually run quick
as they should.
18 minutes. Got six people, not five.
Yeah.
What do you mean you forgot six, not
five? How's that affect the time?
Change the access to real time and you
call it a day.
Okay, this is getting lift.
Yeah, now that we have all the stuff
like total chaos or update epox does
something.
It's kind of hard to see be, but this is
the the green curve down here. This was
our baseline before,
and now it looks like we're getting lift
here.
That how far away you do from doing
something like OpenAI 5 if you can
already train for such a long time. Two
problems with Open AI5. One, no matter
what you do, you will need 50,000 CPU
cores to run Dota. All right.
uh and two
the observation structure is really
obnoxious to make fast.
So I think that the result like I like I
wrote in the paper I think that the
neural MMO result is a better result
than emergent tool.
Dota is still like Dota is still pretty
hard.
99.9999
required Spencer
Literally need to be able to just run
the policy on an actual car and have it
somehow work.
There's a car that's physically in the
way and there's another one behind you.
There's no way to escape. Quantum tunnel
through the car. Figure it out, man.
The uh the environment Spencer is
working on is a collab with NYU.
You can actually fiddle with pretty darn
recent version of it on the website of
all the cars.
You can actually hold like space and go
into first person mode
and it simulates these like short little
driving scenes. We're adding much longer
scenes to this as well.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
There are a couple pretty cool RL labs
over there.
Sadly, not a ton going on at MIT at the
moment as far as I'm aware. Otherwise,
we'd be, you know, we'd support them.
Little annoying.
slightly worse in terms of time
than the uh the previous one.
We'll go back to two update epochs.
Hopefully this saves a policy for us. I
don't know if I'll get to actually check
it before I got to run for dinner in
case I do have to run because I'll have
to just go all of a sudden. Um,
for folks watching,
puffer.ai for all the things, the GitHub
to help us out. It's free. really helps
us out. It's all open source and uh
yeah, join the Discord if you want to
actually get involved with building some
of this cool stuff.
We've had several people come in with
like either no AI background or even
some with no programming background been
able to get up and running pretty
quickly. Like we try to make it pretty
easy. There's also a b there a whole
bunch of resources on here to help you
as well. The blog, we have more articles
on X, lots of things.
I honestly don't even know if it needs a
bigger network at all.
I think that's a new peak for the
stream. That's uh I can never tell how
many on X, but that's at least 14
concurrent. So, cool.
Thanks for uh dropping in, folks. I got
to run for dinner. I will be back either
after dinner or tomorrow. See how I'm
feeling. Uh and I'll keep working on
robotics
large scale tactical battle end and all
that. So, thank you and uh have a nice
evening.